i went to a little christmas eve party i  had a great time there i uh insulted the  host  um how'd that happen what went down  there  i uh i told him that he's bipolar uh  why did you tell him that he was bipolar  what did he do to deserve that because  he was just going like whoa guys i'm  here and i'm gary faust and i'm crazy  [Laughter]  [Applause]  that's an actual guy's name who you just  said just there you actually threw in  the guy's name i get the feeling even he  wasn't crazy enough to say his own name  but you just  exaggerated that yourself to really just  get your own [ __ ] final dagger in huh  you insult him at his own party and then  you go to your hit podcast the next  [ __ ] week and make fun of him  publicly  look at you i think he likes that  yeah he likes he likes torture he  definitely does  well